[Music]
imagine a world in which you see numbers
and letters as colored even though
they're printed in black in which music
or voices trigger a swirl of moving
colored shapes in which words and names
fill your mouth with unusual flavors
jail tastes like cold hard bacon while
derek tastes like earwax
welcome to synesthesia the neurological
phenomenon that couples two or more
senses in four percent of the population
a synesthete might not only hear my
voice but also see it taste it or feel
it as a physical touch
sharing the same root with anesthesia
meaning no sensation synaesthesia means
join sensation having one type such as
colored hearing gives you a 50 chance of
having a second third or fourth type
1 in 90 among us experience graphemes
the written elements of language like
letters numerals and punctuation marks
as saturated with color some even have
gender or personality for gale three is
athletic and sporty
nine is a vain elitist girl by contrast
the sound units of language or phonemes
trigger synesthetic tastes for james
college tastes like sausage as does
message in similar words with the edge
ending
synesthesia is a trait like having blue
eyes rather than a disorder because
there's nothing wrong in fact all the
extra hooks endow synthetes with
superior memories for example a girl
runs into someone she met long ago let's
see she had a green name deezer green
deborah darby dorothy denise yes her
name is denise
once established in childhood pairings
remain fixed for life
synesthetes inherit a biological
propensity for hyperconnecting brain
neurons but then must be exposed to
cultural artifacts such as calendars
food names and alphabets the amazing
thing is that a single nucleotide change
in the sequence of one's dna alters
perception in this way synesthesia
provides a path to understanding
subjective differences how two people
can see the same thing differently
take shawn who prefers blue tasting food
such as milk oranges and spinach the
gene heightens normally occurring
connections between the taste area in
his frontal lobe and the color area
further back
but suppose in someone else that the
gene acted in non-sensory areas you'd
then have the ability to link seemingly
unrelated things which is the definition
of metaphor
seeing the similar in the dissimilar not
surprisingly synesthesia is more common
in artists who excel at making metaphors
like novelis vladimir nabakov painter
david hockney and composers billy joel
and lady gaga
but why do the rest of us
non-synesthetes understand metaphors
like sharp cheese or sweet person
it so happens that sight sound and
movement already map to one another so
closely that even bad ventriloquists
convince us that the dummy is talking
movies like lloyds convince us that the
sound is coming from the actors mouths
rather than surrounding speakers
so inwardly we're all sinists outwardly
unaware of the perceptual couplings
happening all the time
crosstalk in the brain is the rule not
the exception
and that sounds like a sweet deal to me
you